hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast rapid whole genome
sequencing in the NICU and PQ decreases
infant morbidity and mortality presented
by Stephen Kingsmore president and CEO
Rady Children's and steel for genomic
medicine I'm Alexis Krause of lappers
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth labyrinth is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before I begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left your screen and type your
question into the drop down box that
appears on the screen once there as many
of your questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to attain your
credits please join me and welcoming dr.
Kingsmore I will now turn the
presentation over to him good afternoon
everybody welcome to my office here in
sunny San Diego so this afternoon I'm
going to talk about rapid whole genome
sequencing thank you and hopefully show
you we are decreasing or bida Z and
mortality for our youngest and most
fragile patients I have no disclosures
we're gonna start with a case report
dates back to October of last year and
this is family 243 enrolled in one of
our research studies the little boys
called maverick and he was
through our neonatal intensive care unit
from the emergency department not a
presenting complaint that's status
epilepticus that means
unremitting seizures so seizure after
see here after seizure the background is
that he his mum is that twenty three
years old and she's previously had at
one child
pregnancy was uncomplicated with the
exception that ultrasound picked up a
slight increase in the size of Mavericks
ventricles he's delivered at a nice site
hospital by c-section and was doing well
afterwards discharged home on day of
life three ring well until eight days of
age when he started to see resulting so
a case like this is a medical emergency
and we started to evaluate what was the
cause of his seizures in order to give
him the appropriate treatment one of the
first tests is an electroencephalogram
she's shown on the right hand side and
that showed two things first of all the
spiky activity is actually seizure
activity second thing is that the
background profile which should be wavy
instead was very flattened fell this
first suppression this combination of
seizure activity and burst suppression
is rather ominous and it's very severe
potentially lethal form of neonatal
seizure disorder as part of his workup
he was given an intravenous dose of
paradox and vitamin b6 and there was no
change
as a result of that suggesting that he
did not have vitamin b6 responsive
epilepsy he had a brain CT scan which
was negative in terms of illuminating
why he was seizing so
no evidence of intraventricular
hemorrhage or acute birth injury he was
worked up for infectious diseases and
other common cause of seizures that was
negative and he had a lumbar puncture
performed which showed that his lactic
acid level the server spinal fluid was
grossly elevated at 6.3 this indicates
that he was really critically ill and
that these seizures were resulting in
brain damage and finally is that serum
CK was also grossly elevated although
not to the extent that so over the next
12 hours his disease progressed this is
a note from his medical record last
night was rough with ongoing seizures
continued despite the first line by the
following morning seizures were not any
better now worked his way through our
entire list of drugs for anti epilepsy
and the epileptic drugs and he was on a
midazolam drip that Sebenza diazepam and
the dose of that is increased until he
stopped seizing
unfortunately in his case he continued
to see and the trip was increased until
he purges failure this juncture our
pediatric neurologist dr. goal started
to discuss the prognosis with his mom
and dad and let them know that this
particular form of neonatal cephalopoda
associated with a bad prognosis prepare
them for what the future might hold so
we have several questions at this point
in this little baby's case once you talk
differential diagnosis obviously you
can't
me but be thinking about that what do
you think is the top differential what's
the next test the order by Forex paste
and then why would you order that how
might it be impactful this particular
baby out Rady Children's Hospital
the next test ordered was rapid a whole
genome sequencing and we're going to go
over in the next couple of slides the
answers to these questions so first of
all looking at babies in the NICU or in
the pediatric intensive care unit thank
you
this slide summarizes kind of the state
of the art in terms of management of
these cases
so what 15% of babies are infants they
admitted to the NICU or a PICU in that
first year of life they'll immediately
receive empirical treatment based on the
top a suspicion of they'll get better or
worse going around the circle response
to that they'll have modifications to
their treatment and all the wild
earliest search but the underpinning
etiology underlying the reason that they
are in an average it takes about 60 days
to reach a diagnosis using traditional
genetic tests clearly in the case of
maverick many babies infants that's far
too long too late and so we've developed
rapid whole genome sequencing circumvent
this with a 60 day turnaround babies
frequently been discharged home were
transferred to palliative care or indeed
died prior to a diagnosis precision
medicine is really vital for babies with
seizure disorder on the right-hand panel
there are listed a number of genes
because seizures in babies and a
specific treatment regimen which it's
not the standard test that treatments
that we would give to babies or seizures
it's listed on the right and so in the
absence of knowing what causes a baby
seizure you don't really know which
treatments in fact amongst the a
thousand known genetic diseases there
are over 850 cause seizures and such as
guessing which seizure disorder this
baby might have is almost universally
going to result in a wrong gas and
thereby likely a wrong treatment regimen
in fact these diseases are the leading
cause of death genetic diseases this is
not a small problem around around the
country by 370 inborn errors of
metabolism for example some metabolic
conditions or biochemical conditions are
associated with seizures and 90 of those
ineffective treatments if we diagnose it
promptly enough you have an effective
treatment and prevent the baby from
having any further neurologic airman and
so over the last several years we've
developed methods make a diagnosis by
rapid full genome sequence or our WGS
about two days which allows us to
provide rapid precision medicine and
improve outcomes so let's just walk
through that together this particular
case so the first thing to do is for mom
and dad to give consent for their babies
genome to be decoded Mavericks mum and
dad gave us that second we take a small
blood sample which we race across to our
genome Center which is located on the
other side of the campus from our
neonatal intensive care unit there one
of our certified labardi specialists
such as Luca shown here prepares that
DNA for sequence II that's a step called
library preparation and it takes about
two and a half hours next we load
library which contains the genome
sequence onto an Illumina genome
sequencing here Sarah's shown loading
one such instrument in our facility
where she used this technology recently
set the Guinness world record for
fastest genetic diagnosis it takes about
15 and a half hours for us to decode the
genome 45 times next comes a
computational phase where we go from
that
125 billion letters of DNA that's the
equivalent of about 45 Empire State
building's if we were to actually type
this out on pages 8 knock by 11 pages it
would be 45 Empire State Building level
quite staggering
so that's 125 billion letters and using
technology from medical genome in about
30 minutes take that that's a 2.8
billion letters of Mavericks individual
genome sequence he assigned and then
secondly identify the 4.9 million
letters where Mavericks genome is
different from the reference genome
sequence so it's in this space we're
looking for the cause of his illness the
next thing we do is to go back to his
medical record which is shown on the
right in the slide he used a different
technology from a different company
called clinic think to perform natural
language processing that means that
we're using machines to read the medical
record and identify all of the clinical
features that characterized
Mavericks illness and what you can see
here highlighted is the word seizures
and not only does this program pick up
all of those features but it also
translates into machine readable terms
all human type ontology terms which
allows us to automate making a diagnosis
this step takes about 20 seconds here we
see Mavericks features all of the
features of this disease in a couple of
different colors the red circles are the
actual features that we observed in his
medical record blue features are what
you'd expect to see in his disease
according to one of our textbooks called
online Mendelian inheritance man and
then in gray dark gray to features worse
the weather see an overlap between the
textbook description of his disease and
what we're actually observing in his
medical record and this just underscores
that in babies one of the reasons is so
difficult to make a diagnosis is because
features of their illness looks so
little like the textbook description
basically there's a lot going on in a
newborn baby some of it related to the
genetic disease some of the fact that
he's a newborn some of it relating to
the fact that he's in an intensive care
unit and so this really confounds the
ability to make a diagnosis based on
observation and clinical expertise we
looked at 76 babies with genetic
diseases we were able to measure just
how divergent they were from the
textbook so the blue box here on the
right is the textbook description of the
average number of features in each child
and their genetic disease the red circle
shows what we observe in the medical
record of those children and you can see
the overlaps only three features out of
about 93 amazing our little concordance
there is and then if we use just human
at reading of the medical record to
identify what we perceive to be the
klique the key features on average we
only extract five and they have very
little overlap with attacks
look only 0.9 and so machines can do the
job better than humans and give us a
more accurate picture than a more
comprehensive picture so the next step
in analysis involves the medical record
the first thing we do is to remove all
of the variants in Mavericks genome
which are common maverick has an unusual
condition
it cannot be caused by a common variant
and a genome so I guess it's about
700,000 variants that are left
next we identify the letter changes that
could cause disease that's those that
based on a whole bunch of prediction
algorithms and database lookups we think
these variants might cause disease and
in maverick that number is 962 and
that's true of everybody who's watching
each of us in our genome have about 5
million DNA variants about 700,000 that
are uncommon and about a thousand that
could potentially cause disease we then
marry that 962 with the clinical
features that we observe in maverick 159
and then with almost 5000 just over
5,000 genetic diseases including all of
the causes of seizures in babies when we
look at that intersection of 962 by 159
by 5 1 8 2 were left with a single
variant that matches his clinical
features and matches the genetic disease
and that condition is our diagnosis and
here is actually a screenshot of the
software algorithm with that result and
this has occurred about 20 hours after
we started the testing and in this case
maverick has two changes in his genome
a/c changing to a gia cytosine to the
guanosine and iguana scene changing to
an arginine they're both in the same
gene its aldehyde dehydrogenase type 7
subtype a1 or
I'll age 7 a1 we have the chromosome
positions on chromosome 5 at the two
positions shown and one of these the top
one is a missense it changes a glutamic
acid 2 at looming a minor acid for 27 of
the owl h7 a 1 protein and the other
causes a premature stop in the protein
making a truncated protein that's a
hundred and ten a minor acids long one
of these is inherited from mom one from
dad and so mom and dad are carriers
maverick is compound heterozygous for
two variants giving him a diagnosis of
paradox independent epilepsy with one
copy inherited from his mum and his dad
and what's remarkable about that is that
this is a treatable condition and here
we see in this slide on the bottom right
I'll age 7 a 1 this is the protein which
is broken in Mavericks brain and this is
a biochemical pathway showing what that
particular enzyme does it's involved in
the degradation of l-lysine shown at the
top right this is a series of
biochemical steps that degrade diet real
icing so that it can be eliminated in
urine or in bile secretions in Mavericks
case because this protein is broken with
the X there is paradox independent
epilepsy and that means that he has a
buildup of the precursor that's supposed
to get broken down by that protein and
you can see the name for it there am I
know I add two big semi aldehyde or AAS
a so this is building up in Mavericks
brain it spontaneously converts to the
other red circle with p6e both of these
compounds are
I'm partly responsible for Mavericks
symptoms but the other thing is the p6e
shown in the bottom right spontaneously
complexes in the brain with vitamin b6
or Paradoxal 5-phosphate meaning that
there's no free vitamin b6 to
participate in 25 vital biochemical
reactions in his brain and that's the
main reason why maverick is having
severe seizures so as I said this is
treatable
number one we restrict diet real icing
so that he's not making much of these
toxic precursors and second of all we
give him a lot of supplementary vitamin
b6 to overcome the fact that it's being
complex and so 39 hours after enrollment
our lab directors Jamal and Sharif shown
here Carla the neonatologist who's on
call it's about 10:30 at night with the
result on the advice to give maverick
the treatment regimen we just discussed
and so 55 hours after consent that
treatment started triple therapy with
paradox and our vitamin b6 injections
restriction of lysine and
supplementation of arginine and this
combination overcomes in large measure
the biochemical problem that he has
there's a really nice response
his EEG which I showed you in one of the
first slides goes back to a normal
profile the seizure stopped and within
36 hours we've been able to wean him off
all anti epileptic drugs including the
midazolam drip he's able to be extubated
and in fact several days later he's
discharged home now the thing I want to
point out about maverick is that he had
been given a trial dose of paradox and
when he was admitted to see whether he
had this condition and he didn't respond
to it
this is truly a case where had Madrid
not received a rapid genome he almost
certainly would have died that week and
certainly he Lou defied permanent brain
damage and instead he is thriving and
this is a picture of him about a month
ago here in San Diego and you can see
that he's a vigorous little boy and his
mum and dad love him very much
so that's really why we are so excited
about rapid genome sequencing in a NICU
and a PICU it can avoid morbidity in
babies such as maverick and it can even
prevent mortality so let's back off now
and look at the big picture that's one
case but is this generalizable is this
something that could be recapitulated in
neonatal and pediatric intensive care
units around North America so one thing
that we've under done undertaken in the
last year is to do a meta-analysis of
the entire medical literature looking at
genetic diagnosis of genetic diseases in
children either by whole genome
sequencing or WGS exome sequencing which
is about one percent of the genome but
just about all of the genes in the
genome and then the standard test the
sort of gold standard currently which is
called chromosomal microarray what you
can see in this meta-analysis is that
firstly there are a lot of studies in
particular a lot of studies of exome
sequencing not so many yet of genome
sequencing it's just starting to be
broadly used and then there are a lot of
them performed on chromosomal microarray
and you can see the total number of
subjects across all of these studies in
bold at the bottom of each section the
diagnostic utility is shown over on the
right and we have the averages and the
confidence intervals so the average
diagnostic rate the genome sequencing is
41%
the average diagnostic rate in exome
sequencing is 36% the average with the
gold standard is only 10% so clearly
excellent genome sequencing are superior
to chromosomal micro a in giving a
diagnosis with genetic disease to a
child across a great number of studies
but the other thing you'll see is that
there are very wide error bars so across
the studies reported today there's a
great deal of difference from site to
site let's look at this in a bit more
detail and understand what it means
we're going to just look at a series of
studies that my group has done over the
last five years so the first study was
actually the first 35 babies to receive
rapid genome sequencing in the world
right after we invented this technology
and this was published in 2015 the study
was done in Kansas City and we selected
the first 35 babies we thought might
benefit from getting their genome
sequenced as fast as possible now here
are the results from that manuscript so
35 babies had rapid genome sequencing
and in addition because this was an
experimental test they also received all
of the standard tests standard tests
gave only two diagnoses and neither of
those changed how the baby was treated
in contrast 20 babies got a diagnosis by
genome sequencing so 57% versus 6
percent that was a significant
difference second of all 11 of the 20
babies had changes in their management
and four of those or 11%
at a favorable change in outcome and one
their life was saved or 3% so a story
similar to that of Maverick so that was
our very first experience with this
which was really mind altering for all
of us who are involved we realized wow
this is going to transform how babies
are cared for in a NICU and
cute but again this was the first study
it was only a small number of children
we need much more evidence if this is to
become normal
so our second study was a randomized
controlled trial which is the highest
quality of evidence it was funded by NIH
through a program called insight this
picture shows the actual study design so
we assessed 129 babies to see if they
might be eligible for the study and 65
were indeed enrolled and were randomized
either to receive rapid genome
sequencing and all standard tests or to
receive standard tests alone so 32 got
genome sequencing standard tests 33
received standard tests alone now one
thing that we noticed was that our
neonatologists already felt strongly
that genome sequencing was valuable in
these patients and so in many of the
patients they asked us if they could
cross the baby over to receive genome
sequencing and in fact this led to us
terminating this study early we'd
intended to enroll hundreds of babies to
really get definitive proof that genome
sequencing was superior
we had to terminate the study early
because so many of the control babies
are getting genome tests here's the main
result the main conclusion of that study
on the one axis you can see here the
time to diagnosis from 0 to 480 days and
on the other axis the proportion of
babies who received the diagnosis what
you can see is that genome sequencing
gives a higher rate of diagnosis than
standard testing and a much more rapid
diagnosis and in fact between the
asterisks
whole genome sequencing was
statistically better than standard
testing so this is a more at rigorous
test of the diagnostic benefits of
genome sequencing the next thing we
wanted to look at was clinical
usefulness so yes in this study the
insight one study we'd shown that the
test was from a diagnostic test
standpoint better than standard tests
but that didn't speak to whether it
improved outcomes and so then came our
third study which was published in April
of this year which actually looked at
morbidity and mortality and cost of
hospitalization so since the prior study
I had moved with my group and two Rady
Children's Hospital in San Diego and
this study reported the first forty two
babies tested in Rady Children's
Hospital in our Nikki PICU and
cardiovascular intensive care unit one
big difference between this study and
the previous studies is that we were now
testing a much broader swath of children
rather than just those who are cherry
picked as having a high likelihood of a
genetic disease so let's look at the
results together so 42 baby support
enrolled and they received both standard
care and rapid genome sequencing so this
is a cohort study the standard tests
diagnosed the genetic disease in four of
42 babies or 10% one of those babies or
2% of the 42 had a change in treatment
but it didn't change the babies outcome
in contrast rapid genome sequencing made
a diagnosis and eighteen of the babies a
13 of the 18 had a change in management
11 or 24 6% of the total had a change in
outcome that is remarkable we can change
the outcome in about a quarter of the
babies in an intensive care unit
who meet these very simple and Ruhlman
criteria shown at the top
so with this study we looked in a little
bit more detail than at the economic
impact it's gonna take me a little
minute to unpack this slide because it's
a little complex but let's get into it
so the first baby that we modelled has
niemann-pick type C or MPC 1 and we
reckoned that the impact of rapid genome
sequencing was to shorten the time to
diagnosis from 15 days of hospital stay
to 8 days or a 7 day decrease and that's
because during his first admission he
had not been had available rapid genome
sequencing it wasn't until his second
admission but we were able to offer the
test and we made a diagnosis and our
Delphi panel argued that had the tests
been available during his first
admission we would have made a diagnosis
earlier and so the avoided cost was
figured to be the cost of the second
admission which was $27,000 he then
started on an experimental treatment for
niemann-pick type C called Mingus stat
at 2 months of age and we believe that
he's one of the youngest children ever
to have started treatment with that
medication the second child is a really
quite tragic this is a baby who was had
been in the NICU for 250 days by the
time we started to do rapid genome
sequencing he was not expected to have a
genetic diagnosis but when we tested him
we found that he had arid 1b variant
that was pathogenic giving him a
diagnosis of cough and Syrus syndrome
and given his total medical picture his
parents decided that he opted received
palliative care I don't have time to go
into his medical condition but it was
incredibly severe he'd had multiple
surgeries multiple episodes of ECMO and
he was in septic shock at the time his
diagnosis was made and he died the day
palliative care was started had he not
about this diagnosis he would have
started that day treatment for this
newly diagnosed septic shock which would
have lasted at least at least six weeks
with intravenous antibiotics in an
intensive care unit and so we avoided in
his case three hundred and twenty seven
thousand dollars of needless care which
wouldn't have benefited him in fact you
could argued that had our tests being
available early in his course he
probably would have had this test
performed before his first surgery and
we may have actually saved much of the
1.9 million dollars but our Delphi panel
thought that we could not really predict
what his parents decision-making would
have been and so they went with this
more conservative number a third case
very simple a floppy baby something we
see every week and this baby got a
prompt diagnosis of namland myopathy and
avoided the need for a muscle biopsy
electromyogram with the muscle biopsy
under general anesthesia saving about
ten thousand dollars a remarkable case
is the next one this is a baby with
Alagille syndrome this baby was in the
operating room about to undergo an
operation called a Kasai hepatic were to
enter ostomy for treatment of a
different condition called biliary
atresia and so his entire workup pointed
to biliary atresia but in fact that
wasn't the correct diagnosis and we just
managed to stop that surgery from
happening in the operating room
had he had that surgery there's a like
eighty percent likelihood he would have
died so he probably saved his life and a
100% likelihood that he would have
needed a subsequent liver transplant as
in his case from an economic standpoint
we saved the cost of the Kasai operation
a risk-adjusted percentage of the cost
of a liver transplant and I'm not sure
what happened to my slides I think I
lost the bottom of this slide so there
are two more cases nothing ever goes
according to plan there are two more
cases one is a miracle baby who had a
presentation identical to that of
maverick a baby with the same EEG
profile who turned out to have a very
different condition called OSA Harris
syndrome we were able to make a
diagnosis in her she's called Sebastiana
and get her on the correct treatment
that within a couple of days and again
we avoided about a month of prolonged
duration in the NICU because of that she
was able to go home before Christmas and
the last baby a baby with neonatal
hypoglycemia also in that bit that's cut
off at the bottom of the slide and again
we were able to shorten the hospital
stay by about a month by identifying the
cause of that baby's hyperinsulinism as
focal congenital hyperinsulinism which
changed the surgical procedure and
allotted that baby to go to surgery a
month earlier than would be normal if we
add up all of these cases and the costs
avoided it came to $800,000 and even NAT
of testing all 42 families by genome
sequencing that was a significant amount
of cost savings for the hospital so not
only does genome sequencing save lives
and avoid morbidity but at least in this
set of 42 babies it resulted in lower
health care costs this is something
we're phenomenally excited about because
it means that it's likely that this will
become reimbursed and therefore
something that many hospitals will be
able to adopt in the next year or two
and here is Sebastiana that's the little
baby who has Oda hara syndrome and
here's her mum and dad talking about
their experience at a conference we
recently had and if you'd like to you
can read all about her story because it
was in Time magazine in September 2017
and you can read all about sebastiana in
more detail so we're coming to the end
well here it is that was cut off on the
previous slide so my slides are just
mixed up so this is the story where we
were able to save one hundred and eighty
one thousand dollars in in Espace
Tiana's case and a hundred and twenty
five thousand dollars in the case of
baby with hypoglycemia associated with
focal like where insulin isn't so our
strategy is to bring genomic medicine
first for the sickest two-and-a-half
percent of children so we've looked over
claims codes in a very large database of
the company Milliman of 40 million
covered lives and we figured out that
about 15% of NICU admissions would meet
eligibility according to their codes in
terms of billing for rapid genome
sequencing and we believe that we would
be able to improve their outcomes to
give additional quality adjusted life
years and we looked at their charges and
each of these babies on average cost the
healthcare system about a quarter of a
million dollars in the first year of
life so we really do believe that what
I've shown you is something that's going
to be generalizable right now we're
doing a new clinical trial
we've now enrolled actually this is a
little outdated
about a hundred and forty-three babies
in this trial where we're comparing
genome and exome sequencing and
evaluating the need for either singleton
testing versus testing mom dad and baby
and over the next year the shoot of the
results
this study as we enroll 250 infants we
think this will be the pivotal study to
really convince folk that genome
sequencing is the new gold standard for
such babies but I want to show you just
one or two early results from that that
ongoing study so first of all we're
screening 44% of our NICU admissions
it's a very broad group of babies for
this trial overall we're finding that
even looking at this many babies almost
half of the NICU babies our rate of
diagnosis is still quite high at 21% and
so far we're finding that you don't need
to sequence mum and dad as well that
only gains us one percent more diagnosis
what we've been asking the physicians
caring for these babies is in your
opinion is rapid genome sequencing or
exome sequencing useful 91 percent say
yes where their baby got a diagnosis but
more interestingly 71 percent of babies
who didn't get a diagnosis are still
saying the genome sequencing is very
valuable in helping them to manage the
baby so ruling out genetic conditions in
some cases is as important as ruling in
a genetic condition in terms of helping
decision making in the NICU and PICU
then we ask parents do you feel you
understand your results that we gave you
70% said yes 30% said sort of none said
no so that's very good one of our
concerns was that this might be
overwhelming for parents of children in
an intensive care unit turns out that
doesn't seem to be the case and then we
asked the parents did you think that
genome testing was useful in your baby
100% whose babies received the diagnosis
said yes 94 who received a genome
sequencing didn't diagnose the genetic
sees said yes
only 4% said no that's a very surprising
force that's much more positive than we
had anticipated and in fact one of our
concerns and the reason why we did this
study was that we were concerned that we
might provoke anxiety and feelings of
guilt or other potentially harmful
outcomes in doing genome testing in
young babies that doesn't seem to be the
case so let's wrap it up and with the
last slide or the penultimate slide
rapid early genomic sequencing in the
NICU PICU and CV ICU we feel is going to
be applicable to about 10% of infant's
the diagnosis rate is going to vary
based on how many infants you test
between 20% and 60% overall the studies
are consistently showing the 31 percent
of babies are tested will have changes
in treatment as a result of testing
somewhere between an 11 and 26 percent
that's pretty broad still but that's 10%
to a quarter one and ten to one and four
it's gonna change the outcome for the
baby in a favorable manner and one to
three percent is what we can expect in
terms of lives saved this is a
revolution and then in addition to that
the perceptions both of pediatricians
and the children's parents are
overwhelmingly that this is useful in
their opinion and so this is our figure
here of what we think a NICU or a pic
use day will look like in maybe five
years time but these things that I've
shown you today will be normal but we
will have daily artificial intelligence
scrutinizing the medical record too
polite for computers to animal
what's going on in the babies symptoms
it will be same day testing looking at
the genome assisted by artificial
intelligence feeding off the medical
record to give rapid results and the
precision medicine will be normal in
intensive care units and it won't just
be for standard treatments either that
will start increasingly to have clinical
trials of new treatments for babies
whose conditions currently are untreated
with the goal of really changing so
that's my slides thank you very much for
listening to me I'd like to acknowledge
that this work was done by a really big
team I'm speaking but it just took a
team of about 50 people to do this work
and our collaborators are listed in the
bottom right it's taken the help of
several biotechnology companies and
we're very grateful for funding support
from the National Institutes of Health
thank you very much thank you dr.
Kingsburg for that informative because
we will now start the live Q&A if you
have a question you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left to your presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on the screen and click send
button well answer as many of your
questions as we have time for so let's
get started our first question is what
are the benefits of whole genome
sequencing versus whole exome sequencing
well that's a good question I think we
alluded to this that this latest
clinical study we're in the middle of is
set up to answer that question in the
meta-analysis I showed they appear to be
fairly comparable but exome sequencing
is less expensive than genome sequencing
it's a bit slower than genome sequencing
by about a day so right now we're trying
to weigh up
the benefits versus the increased cost
and decide what you become the first
line of test and right now I can't
answer that but this new study that we
are starting or error in the middle of
hopefully will answer that question
unequivocal our next question is what
needs to happen in order for the whole
genome sequencing becoming a part of
standard care for babies with rare and
undiagnosed diseases well that's again
that's a tough question three things
need to happen first of all what I'm
showing you is still somewhat
experimental we're a research
institution and so it's not available in
most children's hospitals around the
country and around the world and so the
first thing we need to do what we call
implementation science which really
means he mystifying genome sequencing
and making it available to Children's
Hospital's worldwide during the process
of doing that as are others and by the
end of this year predict that this will
be available in probably about 75
children's hospitals around the world
that's the first big step
the second big step is to build a
evidence base but I today reviewed the
world's evidence base and really it's
only for studies there might be one or
two others as part of the evidence-based
certainly less than 10 studies so as a
community a scientific community we need
to build the evidence for when this
works oil works
I'm persuade our colleagues all around
the world that this is the best
treatment and when it's the best
treatment and then the third thing is
actually to educate intensivists us
neonatologists and doctors with an
intensive care units they are not used
to this they've probably never used this
not familiar with these principles that
I shared with you today and so there's a
big job to do to educate said there were
three but there's actually four the
fourth one is right now it's still an
experimental test it's not reimbursed by
by pay ORS
that's another piece of the puzzle this
needs to be covered by your health
insurance plan dr. Kingsmore how is our
CI GM working to expand access to rapid
halt genome sequencing so as we develop
these results and we're flabbergasted by
them he said you know we really have a
mission to share this and so over the
last first place we switched on was
Minnesota Minnesota Children's in fall
and Minneapolis the second was Colorado
Children's Denver and the third was
Kunis Hospital of Orange County and know
today we're lie seven children's
hospitals as I said we're growing that
number and by the end of the year
hopefully about 75 children's hospitals
we would like over the next five to ten
years offered in every Children's
Hospital as part of the standard yeah
and it looks like we have time for one
more question how do you expect the
field of genomics to evolve in the next
few years and what can health care
organizations do to prepare prepare for
this change yeah that really ties in to
that first question on my last slide
what does the NICU of the future look
like and I think that all makes testing
genomes are going to be pretty normal I
mean I have to train our physicians
there you can read that aren't our
hospital systems need to retrain our
nurses our genetic counselors so what
can people do to prepare they can get
involved watching this video is a good
start then the next thing would be to
reach out to us we are going in the next
month or two
start to have monthly live WebEx based
case conferences
they're intended for physicians all over
the world just plug in once a month and
hear a story like Sebastiana
or Mavericks so that together we can
learn from one another
is great I would like to once again
thank dr. King's mark for his
presentation I would also like to take
glabrous for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I would
like to let everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through September of 2018 you
will receive an email from laparis
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye